on en a déjà parlé dans ces caches les
marchés sont devenus un peu fous ces
dernières années aujourd'hui un seul
tweet et les bourses du monde entier
peuvent s'emballer
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été reproché
plusieurs fois lots de masques
le patron de tesla ou de space x ayant
une influence tech 1 c'est oui tu peux
faire monter en flèche en titre en
bourse
on l'a vu récemment avec la faire
gamestop ou musk avait participé à
l'énorme coup réalisé par les
boursicoteurs musk avait d'ailleurs été
sanctionnée en 2018 après avoir annoncé
envisager de retirer sa société tesla de
la bourse américaine si le cours de
l'action n'atteignez pas 420 dollars
sanctionné par la sec l'autorité des
marchés américains à qui il entretient
depuis des relations tendues dirons nous
n'hésitant pas à se moquer ou à
provoquer quand il le peut l'asec
l'avait ainsi condamné à une grosse
amende et a dorénavant faire approuver
ces tweets sur tesla afin d'éviter de
faire monter la valeur du titre de
manière artificielle
en somme éviter une manipulation mais
depuis quelques semaines le milliardaire
s'est attaqué à une autre valeur en
pleine expansion le pde coyne faisant
des louanges du crypto actifs sur le
réseau de l'oiseau bleu investissant 1,5
milliard de dollars via tesla et
promettant que ces véhicules pourraient
bientôt être achetés en pipe coyne il a
participé ainsi à faire monter sa valeur
jusqu'à 57 mille dollars
plusieurs accusations de manipulation du
marché crypto ont donc émerger notamment
de l'économiste renommée nouriel roubini
surnommé docteur doom aux états unis
la sec qui colle donc aux basques des
lônes depuis deux ans serait également
en train de lancer une nouvelle enquête
d'autant que début 2000 21 après
l'élection de joe biden l'autorité des
marchés américains s'est trouvé un
nouveau président gary gensler fin
connaisseur du bitcoin est peut être un
adversaire à la mesure des laudes musk
[Musique]